The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we started last
week on the big topic for the
rest of the semester,
optimization.
Maybe can you close that door
or just part way anyway.
Thanks.
Great.
That's perfect, just
like that.
So, since it was a few days ago,
I wanted to recap what I
did in the first lecture about
optimization, which was to
pick out the least squares
problem as a
beautiful model problem.
I followed that through --
the input is a matrix a
rectangular, a right hand side
b probably measurements.
We would like to get au
equal b but we can't.
We got too many measurements.
We do the best possible, which
is the solution u hat of this
normal equation.
Then I rewrote the normal
equations -- well, I also drew
the picture that you see
over here on the left.
The picture that shows
the two optimization
problems at the same time.
Here is the vector b.
Here are all possible au's --
this is the column space,
this is all au's.
The best au was the
projection.
The error e was what we couldn't
get right, the part
that's perpendicular to the
column space we can't help.
It's the solution to another
projection problem that e is
the same -- of course, it's
the same over here -- as
projecting b onto this
perpendicular line, which is
the line of all vectors,
a tranpose e says --
what that says in words is
e is perpendicular to the
columns of a.
I've drawn it the best
I could as a
perpendicular to the columns.
So that we have a plane
of columns --
this is like a 3 x 2 matrix.
We have a plane with the
two columns and the
perpendicular line.
Then just near the end, I said
that it would be great to have
-- this model would be almost
all we need except it should
have one more matrix and
I call that matrix c.
I want just to show you quickly
where that comes.
So this is all section 7.1 of
the notes, except that these
words are not yet typed.
So they'll, as soon as possible,
and an updated 7.1
will include this, what
I want to do.
Because I think it's the very
best introduction I could give
to these pair of optimization
problems.
You might think who needs
optimization.
Your main activity
might be solving
differential equations.
So, can I just take a time out
here because I happened to see
the homework upcoming.
I think it's 16930, so it's a
course a little bit like this,
only the first word in the
course title is "Advanced,"
and our first word is
"Introduction," but, of
course, it's the same course
or same stuff.
This is the homework that I
don't think has even been
assigned, even been
handed out yet.
But I just thought it's a great
example of a applied, so
that you see where optimization
appears and
what's involved.
So differential equations are
involved, but also you got
something that you
want to optimize.
So I just wrote it on this board
and I simplified it a
little over the homework that
they'll actually get.
so here's the problem.
We want a certain distribution
of heat.
So I could draw a picture.
We want a heat distribution for
whatever reason that maybe
goes like this over the
integral zero to 1.
What do we have at our
disposal to get the
heat to be that way?
Well, we've got sources
of heat.
But we don't have a continuous
source, we only have n
parameters to play with.
I mean right away
you recognize an
optimization problem.
We're trying to get this
function here u knot of x.
We're trying to match a
function, but we've only got n
parameters.
Those will be the
right hand side.
So what we're allowed to choose,
we can put in little
space heaters, and we can turn
them to the temperatures we
want to -- temperatures
s1, s2, s3.
That was probably a stupid
choice to put an s for down
there because I don't
even know if
negative heat is allowed.
Anyway, we wouldn't want it
if we're aiming for that
distribution.
Now you understand the s's
are not supposed to
match that u knot.
The s's are the sources of
heat, and the u's are the
outputs, the distribution, and
they are controlled by a
differential equation.
What we control is the right
hand side of the equation, but
we only control n parameters.
Then we have to solve the
equation and find out what
distribution that gives.
So that's all like differential
equations, we
know how to do it.
It's one dimensional in this
example, so straightforward.
But now comes the optimization
part.
We take this result
and we compare it
with the desired result.
So the actual result from some
source of heat might be
something like that.
We want this u of x, the heat
distribution that we're
actually producing to be as
close as possible to u knot.
Close could mean different
things, but if we measure
closeness in this integral
square mean square sense, then
we're going to have
nice problem.
In fact, we're going
to have a linear --
everything's linear right now.
Well, everything's quadratic
here, so when we minimize it's
going to give us a linear
equation for the s's.
I just think that's a
good model problem.
A good model of what
we might do.
I think actually in the problem
to be assigned --
well, it's not a big
deal for us.
There is convection as well.
So this is a pure diffusion
problem, just the second
derivative.
We know very well that if there
was a first derivative
in there, the stuff's
convecting, passing through
the region.
So if I put on a convective
term, cdudx, how does that
change the problem?
Not in a big, big major way, but
one thing we can guess is
that now that is not a symmetric
term, right.
We've seen the difference
between first differences and
second differences, first
derivatives and second
derivatives.
So now it's a little trickier
and it's not symmetric.
So somehow there will be a
primal problem, this one, and
there will be a adjoint
problem, dual problem,
perpendicular problem, whatever
name you want to give
it, just as there is in our very
first model over there.
So that's my sort of quick look
to kind of put on the
board one example that I didn't
invent, that came from
applications and gives
a sort of typical of
what you have to do.
You control an input, you get
an output, so that's the
analysis problem.
Find the output.
But then comes the optimization
problem -- make
that output close to something
that you wish.
So what's the typical algorithm
going to do?
It's going to make a choice of
s, it's going to solve the
analysis problem for the u,
it's going to look and see
what the error is, it's going
to figure out probably the
gradient somehow.
What's the steepest way
to make it closer?
That's going to lead us
to a change of s.
We use a change of s, the new
s, solve that, and iterate.
That would be a typical
algorithm.
We might be able to shortcut
it in a model
problem like this.
But that's totally the typical
optimization idea, is an
analysis problem and then figure
out a gradient to get a
better source back to
the analysis problem
with the new source.
What the algebra, the math, has
to do is those two steps
of figuring out OK, how do we
improve the error, how do we
reduce the error, what's
the steepest direction?
Somehow we got to compute
a derivative.
Actually, that's what
this month is about.
Derivatives that are not just
like the derivative of x cube
or something.
I often wondered how many
presidents could take the
derivative of x cube
and I'm not sure.
Anybody occur to you who you
could count on being able to
take the derivative
of x cubed?
I don't think the current
president would
know what it meant.
But I think Carter could have
done it, because he went to
the Naval Academy.
Jefferson was probably --
he knew everything.
I don't know.
Anybody else has another
candidate they can tell me.
So there is our problem --
finding derivatives that would
be definitely beyond the
capacity of the White House.
Now I want to stay with this
model a little more because
it's the perfect model.
So this was the like model 1,
unweighted ordinary least
squared, and it produced the
identity matrix in there.
I mentioned last time what I
want to do, the more general
model has another symmetric
positive-definite matrix in
there, but not necessarily i,
and it comes from weighted
least squares.
So that's what I'm going
to talk about.
So what are weighted
least squares.
Well, you've got these
measurements and you think
they maybe don't all, maybe
they're not independent, maybe
they're not equally reliable.
So you weight them by how
reliable they are.
A more reliable one you would
put a heavier weight, w, on
because you want that to
be more important.
So, you change to
this problem.
But it looks practically
the same.
The only difference is a has
become wa, b has become wb.
So the equations will be the
same, but a is now wa, b is
now wb, and those are
the equations.
I guess I should call, just
to make clear that u is a
different u, that the best
u now depends on
the choice of weights.
I should really be calling that
u -- somehow indicate
that it depends on the weight.
Now they key nice thing is that
if I write this out as a
tranpose --
can you just write this out.
You get the a tranpose, and
the a is over here.
But what's in the middle?
What's this matrix c --
I jumped the gun and called that
matrix in the middle c,
but how is it connected to w?
You can see it here as c
is w tranpose w, right?
It's just sitting there
in the middle.
That's great that the fact
that the combination w
tranpose w is all you
need to know.
So we can forget w
in favor of --
I'll just put it here -- w
tranpose w is now given the
name c, and this matrix is
symmetric positive-definite.
So it's a great matrix and it's
exactly the one we want.
This is exactly the
equation we want.
So if I go back to writing it in
this -- you know, this was
the equation.
You remember the point that we
could go directly to one
equation for the best u, or we
could keep our options open
and have two equations that
led to the same one.
They're totally equivalent.
But the two equations will give
us not only u, but the
error, b minus au, as
an other unknown.
That's what we did up there.
So we had two equations,
and if we
eliminated e we got to this.
Now I want to have two
equations, and if I eliminate
e, I get to that.
So let me see what
those would be.
Well, here's one of them.
a tranpose c -- e is zero --
you see, that's the only
difference really.
That the weighted normal
equation, I just took a
tranpose c, and then I took the
b minus au together, and
this is what I'm calling e.
So one way to do it is just the
new guy is just now e plus
auw is still b.
But now a tranpose ce is zero.
Good deal.
I mean that's quite nice.
It isn't absolutely perfect
though, because
I've lost the symmetry.
I'm putting a c in there and
I don't really want it.
I want a c but I don't
want it there.
So, I just make a
small change.
I'm going to introduce a new
unknown that I'll call little
w, apologies for the fact that
it's also a w, it just
happened to fit.
That'll be the ce.
So I'm just calling this
a new name here.
So that now my e -- of course,
if I just invert, e
is c inverse w.
So now I'm just going to write
these equations with w instead
of e because I like it better.
So this equation is now a
tranpose w equals zero.
This equation e is disappeared
in favor of c inverse w plus
au equals b.
So that's the system
that I really like.
That's the saddle point system,
the Kuhn-Tucker
system, the primal dual system,
the fundamental system
of the whole subject in this
linear matrix case.
We haven't got functions, we
got vectors, and we've got
symmetry, and we've got
linearity, and we've got a
saddle point matrix that's now
the s -- well, let me just
change it here.
It's just changed to
this, c inverse.
That's the fundamental matrix
of the whole subject.
So, s is the saddle
point matrix.
So I wanted to get that far.
You see that the whole picture
was elementary linear algebra.
Let me come back to the
elementary figure that
illustrates what's
the geometry.
How was the geometry affected
by introducing this guy w,
this weighting matrix or the
c equal w transport w?
Well, here was the picture
from last time.
A right angle picture.
This was a right triangle.
This line was perpendicular
to that plane,
but not anymore now.
The second one it's a
tranpose ce is zero.
That's still a line, but it's
not any longer perpendicular
to the -- this is still
all the au's.
This plane is still the column
space of all the au's.
We have the same b, but you see
the problem is it lost its
90 degree angle, because
the projection is now a
projection, it's now an oblique
projection, it's slanted.
This is the best au, and if I
occasionally keep up-to-date
I'll put that uw there.
There's still an error e, and
this is still a parallelogram
but it's not a rectangle
anymore.
Forgive my enthusiasm.
I'm sort of happy that the
picture and the algebra both
come out so neatly.
I totally agree that at this
point I'm asking you to follow
a model without giving you an
application, and that's one
reason I threw in this mention
of a specific application that
came from somewhere else.
But this is the picture there.
So I'll say one more word
about the picture.
I said that we lost
the right angle.
We lost perpendicularity,
and, of course,
literally speaking we did.
This is no longer -- this is
not a right angle anymore.
This is not a right
angle anymore.
It's not a right angle in the
usual meaning of right angles.
It is a right angle in the
inner product that's
associated with c.
In other words, right
angles here mean x
transpose y equals zero.
That's the idea of a right
angle, right? x perpendicular
to y, and they have different
letters here.
Now over here I still have
perpendicular, but I don't --
this is not the right inner
product anymore.
It should be a weighted inner
product, weighted with this c
in the middle.
So that's really what I
mean by c orthogonal.
Maybe I'll put those
words down.
So this weighted thing is -- if
I can squeeze it, I doubt
if I can -- is c orthogonality,
weighted
orthogonality.
So let me circle the
whole thing.
The c is the w tranpose w.
Just to say that we aren't
giving up on dot products and
perpendiculars and good
equations, we're just changing
them by inserting c every
time in a product.
What it means is that this is
the natural inner product for
the particular problem.
This is the natural inner
product for Euclid, right?
But then from some specific
application like this one or a
million others, they have
their own natural inner
product, and the inner product
for that particular problem
would be one of these guys with
some kind of a matrix c
showing up.
So least squares and weighted
least squares, that's my
example one.
Now I'd like to give a second
example, a more mechanic --
will come closer to mechanics.
Because this is least squares,
statistics, algebra.
But let me put on the
middle board an
application out of mechanics.
It will be, say, I'll make it
small and just a couple of
springs with a mass between them
and fixed at both ends.
So this spring extends
by some amount.
This spring extends
There's a force on this mass.
So there's a force on there
mass, maybe just gravity, f.
That's the external force from
the mass of that's here in
between the springs.
Then also acting on that
mass are spring forces.
This spring is pulling
it up, right?
There's a spring force, w1.
Here, do you want
me to draw --
really which direction
is this?
I'm going to draw it this way
just to show the w2 drawn that
way would actually be negative,
because I think that
this spring would get
compressed, right -- this mass
is pushing it down.
This spring would be
under compression.
It would be pushing
the mass back up.
So the w2 in that picture
would be negative.
So this w1 will actually be
positive and go the way the
arrow is showing.
This w2 would actually be
negative and go not that way
the arrow is showing.
But what's the -- oh, what
equations have we got then?
What's our optimization
problem?
Well actually, we
have a choice.
We could work with equations,
period.
Actually, one of the equations
is pretty obvious.
This mass is an equilibrium.
So w1 is equal to w2 plus s.
So it doesn't move.
Or you might prefer me to write
it, I would rather write
it, with w's on one side and
source terms on the other.
So that's the equilibrium
equation.
So what decides, we want to know
what these w's are, and
these springs are extended.
So that first spring is expanded
by an amount e1, and
this second spring is extended
by an amount e2.
Stretched or compressed.
e1 is probably going to be
positive here -- that spring's
going to be stretched.
This spring is going to be
compressed, so that e2 is
probably going to be negative.
What's the mechanics here?
Well, I can state it two
ways, as I said.
I can state the mechanics in
terms of equations -- force
and stretching elastic
constant.
That's how we did it in the
first semester, 18085.
It's a little clearer because
simple equation
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
Or I can state the problem as
a minimization of energy.
That's what I want to
do today in 1806.
So I want to minimize 8.6.
I want to minimize
the total energy.
The energy in these springs.
Subject to the constraint --
this constraint, equilibrium.
So that's the optimization
statement of
the mechanical problem.
Well, I guess all that
remains is -- well,
I guess what remains?
First of all, I need an
expression for this energy.
If the springs are governed by
Hooke's law, then it'll be
pretty simple.
If they're real springs that
don't quite obey Hooke's law
then there'll be none -- no,
there'll be fourth degree,
sixth degree , whatever,
terms in the energy.
It's like the energy in the
first spring plus the energy
in the second spring, anyway.
e in the first spring, and the
energy in a second spring,
and, of course, the two springs
could have different
spring constants.
So those e's --
I'll make life easy in solving,
if I choose Hooke's
law, if I choose the energy
to be just a square.
The constraint is linear, so
that'll be the model problem.
And actually, that'll be the
kind of problem I've got here.
One reason for introducing a
new example was to get some
mechanics into the lecture,
but also to get a problem
where we're doing a minimization
but we've got a
condition on the w's.
The question is how do
you find a minimum?
You can't just set derivatives
of the energy to zero.
You would discover w1 equal
w2 equals zero.
Nothing happening.
That would be the minimum.
But that minimum is ruled out,
that solution is ruled out
because we have this
constraint.
We've got to balance
the external force.
So this is the question and
you'll maybe have met this
question in other courses,
but it's essential.
How do you deal with minimizing
when there's a
constraint?
I guess in some way we
had it over here.
We were minimizing something --
well, the minimum would be,
take u equal u knot.
But no, there was a constraint
that u had to satisfy a
certain equilibrium equation.
Here it was a differential
equation so that problem is a
little harder than this one
where the equation is just
discrete, one simple equation.
So how are you going to do it?
Well, actually the quickest way
would be -- that's such an
easy constraint that I could
say hey, w2 is w1 minus f.
So I could just, if I wanted to
really like shortcut this
whole lecture, I could say
well, w2 is w1 minus f.
Now I've accounted for
the constraint.
I've removed w2 from
the problem.
I have a minimization, an
ordinary minimization with an
unknown w1.
I take the derivative.
I solve derivative
equals zero.
I find w1, then I go back,
I get that w2.
That's the fast way.
Of course, gets the
right answer.
But there's another way
that in the end
turns out to be better.
It's not necessarily better for
this simple problem, but
it's better for the general
approach to constrained
optimization.
So I'm going to not do the
simple deal of solving for w2,
but I'm going to keep the
constraint around.
It's the idea of Lagrange
multipliers.
You've heard those words and
probably seen it happen.
So what is Lagrange
multiplier?
What is Lagrange's idea?
Lagrange's idea is he
constructed a function of w,
which is this to work with,
which is the same energy.
But he's going to include
a multiplier.
Now the next question is what
letter shall I use for that
multiplier, Lagrange's
multiplier.
Books on optimization often
call it Lambda --
Lambda's sort of like
for Lagrange.
So, Lagrange obviously wasn't
Greek, but anyway -- close.
Lambda for us always
means eigenvalue --
For me always means
eigenvalue.
So I'm reluctant
to use Lambda.
Sometimes in books on economics,
which is we're
doing this all the time, the
multiplier's called pi because
it turns out to be a price.
But let me use u for the
Lagrange multiplier.
So that'll be the Lagrange
multiplier.
So what do I do with it?
I multiply this equation by u
and I build it in to this.
So this thing is this part --
I'll just copy that down there
-- plus or minus, depending
what I want, depending which
sign I want to end up with, u
the multiplier times the
constraint -- w1 minus w2 --
let me put it like that.
So the constraint is that
this should be zero.
So you can say I haven't
added anything.
I've added zero.
But that will only be true
at the end when I have a
specific w1 and w2.
Right now what I've done is I've
built in the constraint
into the function.
Lagrange's brilliant idea was
that now I've got a function
that I can -- my derivatives
I can take.
I could set the derivatives to
zero. dldw1 is going to be
zero. dldw2 is going
to be zero.
And dldu is going to be zero.
So we got now three equations,
three unknown.
Instead of going from two
to one, we've gone
from two up to three.
But it's so much more systematic
that it's the right
thing to do.
What is this last equation?
What's the u derivative
of an expression?
Well, u doesn't appear here, the
derivative is just w1 --
this just leads us to w1 minus
w2 minus f, which is the
constraint that we wanted.
So the constraint is showing
up as this equation.
Just the way the constraint
showed up as
this equation here.
I guess what I want to say is
when I wrote this down, when
we did this first example,
I didn't say here's the
constraint.
I mean that equation kind of
came out from the normal
equations here.
So what we're doing new here is
the constraint equation is
sort of part of the mechanics
and we're asking the question
how do I deal with it.
Here it came out of the
geometry, so it wasn't there
at the beginning so we didn't
have to say how do we deal
with this equation.
It just emerged.
Here it's really forced
on us right away.
So anyway, we've still got to
figure out the derivatives of
those, and I guess I do have
to finally now say
what choice -- yeah.
So this is --
what is this, the derivative
of e1 minus u.
If I take the w1 derivative,
I've got the derivative of v1
with respect to w1.
Then w1 doesn't appear there
but it appears here,
so it's minus u.
This would be the derivative of
v2 with respect to w2, that
second spring minus --
oh maybe plus cu.
Well, those are the
three equations.
Let me move now to the linear
case, just so we see the
beautiful pattern.
So if I make the equations
linear, what's the energy in
Hooke's law spring here if the
extension is e1 and if it
produces a force of w1, I want
to know what is this e1 here.
So let me just remember
Hooke's law.
I think Hooke's law would say
that -- well, there's some
elastic constant c1, so there's
a c1 and a c2 that
tell us how hard or soft
the springs are.
So these are physical
constants.
If I remember right,
the energy --
so I'm going to erase a little
here just to -- well no.
So what is the energy in
that first spring?
You remember, there's a 1/2
of an c1 e1 squared.
That's the energy in a spring
with constant c1 and the
stretch e1.
But now I really want it not in
terms of e1, I want it in
terms of w1, just the
way I did here.
I've got to do the
same thing here.
I want to get to w, because
the constraint
is in terms of w.
What does Hooke's law say?
Hooke's law says w equals ce,
that's Hooke, Hooke's law.
The fourth is the elastic
constant times the stretch.
So in place of the e
I have w over c.
So this is 1/2, e1 squared will
be w1 squared over c1
squared, and then a c1 cancels
-- that's what it looks like.
I guess I'm certainly happy
to see that I'm
coming up with c inverse.
This c is showing up in the
denominator, and that's
exactly the -- so this is what
I mean, this is what I want
for my energy is a 1/2, w1
squared over c1, and a 1/2, w2
squared over c2, and now I was
doing a minus sign because
that kind of goes well with
mechanics where a plus sign
would go well with all the
other applications.
So now I've got explicit
energy.
So now I can say what
this thing really --
the derivative with
respect to w1.
OK.
The derivative with respect
to w1 is just w1 over c1.
Is that what I'm getting?
This is zero.
This says w2 over c2 minus u is
zero, and this one says w1
minus w2 equals f.
Our three equations.
Yes, so I will help kill these
equal signs and just look at
-- oh, that's a plus.
We've got our saddle
point matrix again.
That's the nice thing here.
This is a problem with a 3 x 3
matrix, with three unknowns,
w1, w2, and u.
With right hand side
zero zero and f.
With what matrix?
That looks like a 1 over
c1, zero and a minus 1.
This looks like zero, a 1
over c2 and a plus 1.
This looks like -- oh,
wait a minute.
I don't want this.
w1 minus w2 equal f.
I can live with 1 and minus 1
there, but it's not really
what I wanted.
I wanted the signs to -- you
know what I want here.
I want the transpose of that to
be here, and zero to be in
that block.
So that's what my saddle point
matrix would look like.
Well, let me just say that
I could live with either.
I was aiming for this one
because it's symmetric.
But a lot of people would rather
have the opposite signs
and have the 1 minus 1 there.
I don't care which sign
f has, of course.
Some people these days are
liking this form better
because then it has a symmetric
part and an
anti-symmetric part.
I mean the thing is at some
point we're going to get
problems like this with
thousands of unknowns, and
we're going to think how
do we solve them
and maybe some iteration.
So we might want the matrix to
be symmetric but indefinite,
or we might want a
positive-definite symmetric
part and an anti-symmetric
part.
What we can't have is positive
definite-symmetric.
That's like asking for what
can't happen here.
The combination of the problems
is producing a saddle
point and we can play with that
sign, but we can't make
that zero something -- oh,
we could actually.
What I was going to say is we
can't make that zero something
different, but you could.
That would be a possible
way to --
it's another way people thought
of of solving these
problems is artificially throw
in a big number there, or even
a small number, and push things
towards positive.
Anyway, my purpose today is
essentially completed, that
we're getting out of physical
application after I linearized
and it became a linear equation
and it had that
saddle point form.
So, saddle point form here,
saddle point form here, saddle
point forms everywhere.
I mean we'll have the saddle
point forms for differential
equations, as well as for
matrix equations.
So those are the examples to
sort of hang on to, and it's
section 7.1 that has
a big part of it.
Ah --
I always have one last
thing to say.
What's the meaning of u?
So, u was a Lagrange
multiplier.
Lagrange just like helped us out
by saying OK, there was a
constraint by using one
of my multipliers.
But the point is that
the multiplier
always has a real meaning.
I mention prices before.
Here, what's the meaning of u?
What's the physical meaning of
the Lagrange multiplier.
It turns out to be the
displacement of the math.
It's the dual variable,
so it always has some
interpretation.
In this case, with mechanics
it's the amount, the mass
comes down when the
force asks.
What's more, it also has a
derivative interpretation.
Turns out --
I'll just put turns out that
the Lagrange multiplier u
turns out to be the derivative
of the minimum energy in the
system with respect to
the source term.
It's the sensitivity of
the problem somehow.
I'll just use sensitivity.
You often want to know --
it's actually this quantity
that we need over there.
We want to know how much does
the answer depend on the
source, and that's what the
Lagrange multiplier tells us.
So, if I computed the solution
here, so the notes do this --
maybe I'll leave it
for the notes.
The notes solve this
little problem.
That's easy to do.
They figure out what the energy
is in the springs.
It depends on the right hand
side, f, which is just a
number here.
The energy turns out
to be quadratic.
You can take its derivative and
you find out that it's u.
So that Lagrange multiplier,
that's really a key message,
is an important quantity
in itself.
Here it happens to mean
displacement, which is
obviously crucial quantity, and
in general it tells us the
change in the minimum energy
with respect to a
change in the input.
That sensitivity's a natural
word to use for that.
So that's a final word about --
well, a near to final word
about Lagrange multipliers.
So I'll see you Wednesday and
by that time I'll know more
about the projects and we'll
be moving onward with
optimization.
Good.
Thanks.